tenemos un adolescente que ha estado
mató a este inexplicable un excusable y
primero yo estas son palabras de cariño
compartieron el dolor y el apoyo a su
familia y seres queridos
todos vamos a llegar tarde a
trabajo vamos a llegar tarde a la escuela
vamos a llegar tarde a todos lados
por eso pero por que se fueron
llegó allí yo para mí los que están
desesperado por mi es porque ellos
tener la impresión de que la justicia está cerca
dos puntos de medición que tiene una justicia
para unos justicia para otros
y eso es malo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay ira por todas partes y bien en
es normal porque nos decimos si
lo dejamos pasar nunca hay nada
quien se moverá
Quiero expresarle nuevamente aquí mi
cariño mi solidaridad con sus acciones
que son
inaceptable y calificable y que
por supuesto merece tener una respuesta a la
colmo de la violencia y la agresión
que se ha sufrido
[Música]